In this video, we'll
introduce a method
that is similar to CART
called Random Forests.
This method was designed to
improve the prediction accuracy
of CART and works by building
a large number of CART trees.
Unfortunately, this
makes the method
less interpretable
than CART, so often you
need to decide if you
value the interpretability
or the increase
in accuracy more.
To make a prediction for a
new observation, each tree
in the forest votes
on the outcome
and we pick the
outcome that receives
the majority of the votes.
So how does Random Forests
build many CART trees?
We can't just run
CART multiple times
because it would create
the same tree every time.
To prevent this,
Random Forests only
allows each tree to
split on a random subset
of the available
independent variables.
And each tree is
built from what we
call a bagged or bootstrapped
sample of the data.
This just means
that the data used
as the training
data for each tree
is selected randomly
with replacement.
Let's look at an example.
Suppose we have five data
points in our training set.
We'll call them
1, 2, 3, 4, and 5.
For the first tree,
we'll randomly
pick five data points randomly
sampled with replacement.
So the data could be
2, 4, 5, 2, and 1.
Each time we pick
one of the five data
points regardless of whether or
not it's been selected already.
These would be the
five data points
we use when constructing
the first CART tree.
Then we repeat this process
for the second tree.
This time the data set
might be 3, 5, 1, 5, and 2.
And we would use this data when
building the second CART tree.
Then we would
repeat this process
for each additional
tree we want to create.
So since each tree sees a
different set of variables
and a different
set of data, we get
what's called a forest
of many different trees.
Just like CART, Random Forests
has some parameter values
that need to be selected.
The first is the minimum number
of observations in a subset,
or the minbucket
parameter from CART.
When we create a
random forest in R,
this will be called nodesize.
A smaller value of nodesize,
which leads to bigger trees,
may take longer in
R. Random Forests
is much more computationally
intensive than CART.
The second parameter is the
number of trees to build,
which is called intree
in R. This should not
be set too small, but the larger
it is the longer it will take.
A couple hundred trees
is typically plenty.
A nice thing about
Random Forests
is that it's not as sensitive
to the parameter values
as CART is.
In the next video, we'll
talk about a nice way
to pick the CART parameter.
For Random Forests, as long as
this selection is a reasonable
it's OK.
Let's switch to R and
create a Random Forest model
to predict the decisions
of Justice Stevens.
In our R console, let's start
by installing and loading
the package "randomForest."
We first need to
install the package
using the install.packages
function for the package
"randomForest."
You should see a few lines
run in your R console
and then when you're back
to the blinking cursor,
load the package with
the library command.
Now we're ready to build
our Random Forests model.
We'll call it StevensForest and
use the randomForest function,
first giving our
dependent variable,
Reverse, followed
by a tilde sign,
and then our
independent variable
separated by plus signs.
Circuit.
Issue.
Petitioner.
Respondent.
LowerCourt.
And Unconst.
We'll use the data set Train.
For Random Forests we need to
give two additional arguments.
These are nodesize, also
known as minbucket for CART,
and we'll set this equal
to 25, the same value we
used for our CART model.
And then we need to set
the parameter ntree.
This is the number
of trees to build.
And we'll build 200 trees here.
Then hit Enter.
You should see an interesting
warning message here.
In CART, we added the
argument method="class",
so that it was clear that we're
doing a classification problem.
As I mentioned
earlier, trees can also
be used for regression
problems, which
you'll see in the recitation.
The Random Forest function does
not have a method argument.
So when we want to do a
classification problem,
we need to make sure
outcome is a factor.
Let's convert the variable
Reverse to a factor variable
in both our training
and our testing sets.
We do this by typing the
name of the variable we want
to convert-- in our
case Train$Reverse--
and then type as.factor and
then in parentheses the variable
name, Train$Reverse.
And just repeat this for
the test set as well.
Test$Reverse=as.factor(Test$Reverse)
Now let's try creating
our Random Forest again.
Just use the up arrow to get
back to the Random Forest line
and hit Enter.
We didn't get a warning
message this time
so our model is ready
to make predictions.
Let's compute predictions
on our test set.
We'll call our predictions
PredictForest and use
the predict function to make
predictions using our model,
StevensForest, and
the new data set Test.
Let's look at the confusion
matrix to compute our accuracy.
We'll use the table function
and first give the true outcome,
Test$Reverse, and then our
predictions, PredictForest.
Our accuracy here is
(40+74)/(40+37+19+74).
So the accuracy of our Random
Forest model is about 67%.
Recall that our
logistic regression
model had an accuracy of
66.5% and our CART model
had an accuracy of 65.9%.
So our Random Forest model
improved our accuracy
a little bit over CART.
Sometimes you'll see a smaller
improvement in accuracy
and sometimes you'll see
that Random Forests can
significantly improve
in accuracy over CART.
We'll see this a lot in the
recitation in the homework
assignments.
Keep in mind that Random
Forests has a random component.
You may have gotten a different
confusion matrix than me
because there's a random
component to this method.